qui a déjà dîné avec un grand parent est
en guinée va vraiment jours vous avez
une petite race track genre vous avez
connaissez quand vous mangez genre avec
quelqu'un et vous dites je n'ai pas trop
manger etc et moi je me rends compte
d'un truc c'est que je peux dînait avec
n'importe qui va vous en foutez bête
mais je m'emballe heck je me démonte
mais
c'est vrai ça rigolait est vraiment
voilà y'a pas à metz où je me dis ah
ouais je vais dîner avec lui faut que je
fasse gaffe ah non non je suis vraiment
je suis dans mon repas bon c'est bon je
suis venu pour déjeuner pour dîner quoi
je suis pas du genre non non non je vais
juste prendre quelques feuilles de
salade je m'en rappelle je m'en rappelle
et vous savez à quoi vous voyez aussi
que franchement la société est cruel
c'est au nombre de déjeuner qui sont
annulés ah oui je vous jure que c'est
vrai j'ai pensé à ça la dernière fois
est vrai c vous avez dans ce métier vous
avez souvent des déjeuners avec les mecs
de chez ed avec d'autres animateurs avec
des et c'est vrai que je dis la vérité
moi il n'y avait pas un déjeuner qui se
faisait
toujours deux ou trois jours avant
jamais ils m'appelaient bousculez pas
d'assistant donc il dit oui c'est là si
ce taux c'est le beru de ne pourra
malheureusement pas des jeunes
homosexuels date ultérieurement la date
et la moyenne mondiale et c'est vrai que
je dis sans flagornerie mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je pris parfois pour que
les gens à nouveau et c'est vrai que
personne n'a nulle bah oui mais et c'est
assez vraiment et c'est vrai que moi
j'étais le gars qu'on annule et tout le
temps au déjeuner mathieu d'embauché que
vous connaissez ça non
franchement mathieu obama c'est bon
c'est vrai moi j'ai vécu tout gris bleu
quand j'étais tout jeune j'avais rendez
vous avec franck saurat alors c'est un
grand producteur créateur et qui est un
ami mais bon les producteurs n'avaient
pas mais en fait je monte dans
l'escalier il avait son bureau qui était
ouvert la porte était ouverte et
j'entends ouais non mais là vraiment ça
me casse les pieds dans le sens castaldi
lui l'annuler depuis que je suis pas là
à risque et oui quand même ses
ambassades métier particulier comment ça
non mais c'est vrai dans la relation de
pouvoir comme ça aussi moi j'avais un
seul connaissait un très grand
producteur aussi est en fait si on sait
baronio le van kim encore si on l'annulé
qui est un grand très grand producteur
si par exemple on annulait un déjeuner
le déjeuner suivant qui était qui avait
été menotté et ben par par définition
ils annulaient à son tour même s'il
était disponible pour dire en maths à un
partout la balle au centre
moi je suis baptisée raw est toujours
le pire est lui le pire qui est d'allier
c'est que les gars nul même dégoûtés
non c'est quand je suis arrivé de
bordeaux j'étais fertois kittel j'arrive
au rendez-vous avec dominique cantien
qui dirigeait les programmes pour leur
masse demi est l'appareil le bureau
était ouvert et puis on lui dit il ya
bernard montiel qui attend j'ai attendu
une heure et quart dans le couloir d'à
tf1 là haut et elle était la grande
patronne des variétés et ben on est
devenu amis entre temps mais au début
j'entendais l'a dit ah non il ya un
accent à sheila du sud ouest ah ouais
bah pas et toute ma vie
aujourd'hui vous avez un déjeuner tous
les jours vous êtes très sollicités ou
parle pas des places alors je ne prends
jamais de déjeuner franchement je
déteste la mobilité des jeunes hémois
jeu des deux jeunes des jeunes japon
mais les patrons vous à voir celle pas
pour autant mais je ne les gêne pas je
ne le vois pas si on téléphone quand le
téléphone vous moi je vous croise
souvent au restaurant
junk avec mes copains oui c'est vrai
voilà c'est vrai moi j'ai annulé plein
de déjeuner que mathieu par exemple non
c'est vrai
mais vous pour savoir vous voulez
vraiment vous réveillez douanes
l'athlète et du gaz vers le gars il ya
une demi heure il est encore dans les 18
lancers plus tard oui j'ai oublié
d'aller au maquillage en fait
j'étais en soins du visage tout à
l'heure je n'ai pas pensé situe en soins
du mois alors sur un nouveau projet oui
on ne dévoilera si j'ai un projet pour
vous non alors n'ayez on vous et pour
moi oui à la noce en fait dans les
études ce qui ressort c'est que votre
style est trop terne en ce moment ah
ouais j'ai un truc pour colorer tout ça
c'est le vernis à ongles
talent blouson du marié
non c'est le vernis à ongles dépareillés
j'ai fait une petite simulation avec les
équipes ouais j'ai une petite photo
voilà
savez vous en lisez ça nous en 2020
entre ça et on soin visage tu fout quoi
que tu es génial
alors j'ai chéri sinon moi je déjeune
avec marc demain midi normalement cinéma
bernard montiel bah oui alors je trouve
donne un craquelin de manuel où je rêve
alors franchement oui vous inquiétez pas
ouais pourquoi tu veux fêter demain si
tu veux après demain mais pas demain bon
bah et vous vous parlera après je vous
trouvez quelqu'un mais parce qu'il part
non c'est vrai mais quelqu'un pour
d'avant déjeunent ensemble
si vous voulez aller dit pas sûr j'ai eu
un déjeuner avec un ami michel viendra
avec nous on peut venir dans sa
demande et en plus avec qui j'étais ben
voilà on vous viendriez bas aussi on est
complet
j'aime aussi à
michel ouais alors s'il vous plaît si
mais c'est qui merci à midi on a un ami
a même pas ça va pour vous diriger
vers saint michel c'est qui ce michel
michel noël michel luel tout simplement
ça garcia sait qui c'est mais j'ai dû
rater les gars on ne sait pas dans la
télé joue
tout seul c'est son ami qui l'a écoutée
par édition
on est connu c'est pas bien
déconner je vous dirai ce qu'il est bon
les moustaches
c'était mon voisin tout simplement avec
qui je m'entendais très bien non un
autre michel avec qui je m'entendais
très bien qui était mon voisin qui est
un ami qui avec vos voisins vous mais
c'est plus maintenant c'est un elana
voilà oui mais t'es quoi si vous faire
non mais tu n'as même genre il fait la
fête des voisins non mais n'importe quoi
non mais non mais non
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans la cour avec un grand gars en
face de l'immeuble qui joue aussi
michel ohayon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un batik sinon ce samedi 1
[Rires]
non non non non
non je ne te fait quoi dans la vie
qu'est ce qu'il fait dans la vie s'il
vous plaît il à fort patrimoine y avait
là des sociétés il avait gravi la même
version qu'à la météo devant de gros
problèmes alors voilà là ou là
michel un ami j'embrasse yeux les jeunes
avec lui demain j'ai le droit d'espérer
oui ce serait bien mais vous inquiétez
pas pour y faire demain c'est voilà ce
torrent parisien oui
il va car l'usiné a pas déjà bordeaux
demain la veille que n'appartenant pas
fermé la mission de ma soeur vous allez
nous dire qui c'est ouais bah vous serez
la vire à dîner vous donc c'est vrai
quoi on pourra le dire mais je dois dire
bien un enjeu pour votre avenir ouais
vous signer un deal vous n'avez pas sans
angoisse car le monde est fou d'avoir un
point
[Applaudissements]
m
je
[Applaudissements]